let's say that we have the fraction
nine-tenths and i want to add to that
the fraction
one-sixth
one-sixth what is this
what is this going to equal
so when you first look at this you say
oh i have different denominators here
it's not obvious how i add these and
you'd be right and and the way to
actually move forward is to find a
common denominator to convert both of
these fractions into fractions that have
a common denominator so how do you think
about a common denominator well common
denominator is going to have to be a
common multiple of these two
denominators of 10 and 6. so what's a
common multiple of 10 and 6. and it's
usually simplest to find the least
common multiple and a good way of doing
that is start with the larger
denominator here 10 and say okay is 10
divisible by 6
no
okay now is 20 divisible by 6
no is 30 divisible by 6 yes 30 is
divisible by 6. so i'm just going
through the multiples of 10 and saying
well what is the smallest multiple of 10
that is divisible by 6 and that's going
to be 30. so i can rewrite both of these
fractions as something over 30. so 9
over 10
how would i write that as something over
30. well i multiplied the denominator
i'm multiplying the denominator by 3.
so i've just multiplied the denominator
by 3. so if i don't want to change the
value of the fraction i have to do the
same thing to the numerator i have to
multiply that by 3 as well
because now i'm just multiplying the
numerator by 3 and the denominator by 3
and that doesn't change the value of the
fraction so 9 times 3 is 27.
so once again 9 10 and 27 30 represent
the same number i've just written it now
with the denominator of 30 and that's
useful because i can also write 1 6 with
the denominator of 30.
let's do that so 1 6 is what over 30. i
encourage you to pause the video and try
to think about it so what did we do to
go from 6 to 30 we had to multiply
by 5.
so if we multiply the denominator by 5
we have to multiply the numerator by 5
as well so 1
times 5
1 times 5 is 5.
so 9 10 is the same thing as 27 30 and 1
6 is the same thing as 5 30 and now we
can add
now we can add and it's fairly
straightforward we have a certain number
of thirtieths added to another number of
thirtieths so twenty-seven thirtieths
plus five thirtieths well that's going
to be twenty-seven
that's going to be twenty-seven
plus five
plus five
plus five
thirtieths
plus five thirtieths which of course is
going to be equal to what is this
thirty-two thirtieths
thirty-two
over 30.
and if we want we could try to reduce
this fraction we have a common factor of
32 and 30. they're both divisible by
let's see they're both divisible by 2.
so if we divide the numerator and the
denominator by 2 numerator divided by 2
is 16 denominator divided by 2 is 15.
so this is the same thing as 16 15. and
if i wanted to write this as a mixed
number 15 goes into 16 one time with a
remainder 1. so this is the same thing
as 1 and 1 15. let's do another example
let's say that we wanted to add
we wanted to add
one
half
to
to 11 12
to
11 over 12. and i encourage you to pause
the video and see if you can work this
out
well like we saw before we want to find
a common denominator if these had the
same denominator we could just add them
immediately but we want to find a common
denominator because right now they're
not the same
well what we want to find is a multiple
a common multiple of 2 and 12 and
ideally we'll find the lowest common
multiple of 2 and 12. and just like we
did before let's start with the larger
of the two numbers 12. and we could just
say well
12 times 1 is 12 so as you could view
that as the lowest multiple of 12 and is
that divisible by 2
yeah sure 12 is divisible by 2. so 12 is
actually the least common multiple of 2
and 12. so we could write both of these
fractions as something over 12. so
one-half is what over 12.
well to go from 2 to 12 you multiply by
6 so we'll also multiply the numerator
by 6.
and we see one half and six twelfths
these are the same thing one is one is
half of two six is half of twelve
and how would we write eleven twelfths
as something over twelve
well it's already written as something
over twelve eleven twelfths already has
twelve in the denominator so we don't
have to change that
eleven twelfths and now we're ready to
add
so this is going to be equal to
six
this is going to be equal to six
plus
11
6 plus
11
over 12
over 12. we have 6 12
plus 11 12 is going to be 6 plus 11
over 12.
which is equal to 6 plus 11 is 17
12. if we want to write it as a mixed
number that is what 12 goes into 17 one
time with a remainder 5. so 1 and 5
over 12.
let's do one more of these this is this
is strangely fun
all right let's say that we wanted to
add
we're going to add 3
4
2
we're going to add 3 fourths
to
one fifth
two one
over five what is this going to be and
once again pause the video and see if
you can work it out
well we have different denominators here
and we wanna find this we want to
rewrite these so they have the same
denominator so we have to find a common
multiple ideally the least common
multiple so what's the least common
multiple of four and five
we'll start with the larger number and
let's look at its multiples and and keep
increasing them until we get one that's
divisible by four
so five is not divisible by four
ten is not divisible by four
or perfectly divisible by four is what
we care about fifteen is not perfectly
divisible by four twenty is divisible by
4 in fact that is 5 times 4 that is 20.
so what we could do is we could write
both of these fractions as having 20 in
the denominator or 20 as a denominator
so we could write 3 4 is something over
20.
so to go from 4 to 20 in the denominator
we multiplied by 5. so we also do that
to the numerator we multiplied 3 times 5
to get 15.
all i did to go from 4 to 20 multiply by
5 so i have to do the same thing to the
numerator 3 times 5 is fifteen three
fourths is the same thing as fifteen
twentieths
and over here
one fifth what is that over twenty well
to go from five to twenty you have to
multiply by four so to do the same thing
in the numerator i have to multiply this
numerator times four to get four
twentieths
so now i've rewritten this instead of
three-fourths plus one-fifth it's now
written as fifteen twentieths plus four
twentieths and what is that going to be
well that's going to be fifteen plus
four
is
nineteen twentieths
nineteen twentieths and we're done